This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. We are a waste deep in summer right now, which is a great time of year if you're in the podcast business. Because it's road trip season. Time to hop in the car. Cue up your favorite podcasts. This is 99% Invisible. I'm Roman Mars. And hit the road. That's producer Vivian Lee. And we recently sent her on a 1200 mile road trip through the Midwest.
这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。我们现在正处于盛夏时节，如果你从事播客行业，这可是个好时候。因为这是公路旅行的季节。是时候跳上车，播放你最喜欢的播客了。这里是《99%隐形》。我是罗曼·马尔斯。出发吧。那是制作人薇薇安·李。最近我们派她进行了一次1200英里的中西部公路旅行。
And I saw a lot of things along the way. Bob Dylan's childhood home, a guitar made out of a bedpan, the inside of about 400 boxes of chicken macknuggets, lots of horses. Horses! But we didn't send Vivian out to look for horses or to check a few states off her bucket list. chicken McNuggets, lots of horses. Oh, horses! But we didn't send Vivian out to look for horses, or to check a few states off her bucket list. She was on a mission that required equal parts science, philosophy, and daring. In search of something that's been hotly contested for decades, the world's largest ball of twine. I began my quest by following in the footsteps of the great Weird
沿途我看到了很多东西。鲍勃·迪伦的童年故居，一把用便盆做的吉他，大约400盒麦乐鸡的内部，还有很多马。马！但我们派薇薇安出去并不是为了看马，也不是为了完成她遗愿清单上的几个州。麦乐鸡，还有很多马。哦，马！但我们派薇薇安出去并不是为了看马，也不是为了完成她遗愿清单上的几个州。她肩负着一项既需要科学、哲学，又需要勇气的任务。去寻找几十年来一直备受争议的东西——世界上最大的麻绳球。我的探索始于追随伟大的“怪人”
Alliankovik. To a twine ball I heard about in Minnesota. About an hour west of St. Paul is a tiny little city called Darwin. It isn't the kind of place you'd expect to find a great wonder of the world. The population is only about 350. I accidentally circled the entire downtown in about two minutes while looking for parking. The main street is only three blocks long. There's a bank, a water tower, and a 9 ton ball of twine entombed in a Plexiglas Casibo. So it says, uh, world's largest ball of twine made by one man.
阿连科维克的脚步。去寻找我在明尼苏达州听说的一个麻绳球。在圣保罗以西约一小时车程的地方，有一个叫达尔文的小城市。它不是那种你会期望找到世界奇迹的地方。人口只有350人左右。我在找停车位时，不小心在两分钟内绕了整个市中心一圈。主街只有三个街区长。那里有一家银行、一座水塔，还有一个装在有机玻璃凉亭里的9吨重麻绳球。上面写着，呃，由一个人制作的世界上最大的麻绳球。
It's very round, very round and nicely shaped. It's hard to get a good look from the outside because of the reflection of the glass, but once you press your face up against those windows, you'll see this enormous perfectly round orb that's comprised of brown twine. The ball is the pride of Darwin. But before Courtney Johnson moved here, she had never even heard of it. When I first came to the area, I didn't know anything about the twine ball. Johnson's husband grew up in Darwin, so she asked him.
它非常圆，非常圆，形状很好。因为玻璃的反光，从外面很难看清楚，但一旦你把脸贴在窗户上，你就会看到这个巨大的、完美的球体，它是由棕色的麻绳组成的。这个球是达尔文的骄傲。但在考特尼·约翰逊搬到这里之前，她甚至从未听说过它。当我第一次来到这个地区时，我对这个麻绳球一无所知。约翰逊的丈夫是在达尔文长大的，所以她问了他。
I was like, what is this? And he's like, it's the twine ball, and I kind of laughed at it because it is kind of silly. If you think about it, and he's like, don't laugh, because we're related to them. Courtney's husband is a distant nephew of Francis Johnson, the man who rolled the Darwin twine ball. And she and her husband actually inherited
我说，这是什么？他说，这是麻绳球，我当时笑了，因为它确实有点傻。如果你仔细想想，他说，别笑，因为我们和他们有亲戚关系。考特尼的丈夫是弗朗西斯·约翰逊的远房侄子，弗朗西斯·约翰逊就是那个滚动达尔文麻绳球的人。她和她丈夫实际上继承了
the Johnson family farm. Which is where the story of great great uncle Francis and his giant ball of twine begins. I'd like to tell you that Francis Johnson had a vision of doing something majestic, rolling the largest ball of twine the country'd ever seen. But the truth is he just had too much twine lying around. Johnson was a farmer and his farm, like all farms really, was lousy with twine. And one day in 1950 while cleaning up after his nephew Harlan, Johnson started rolling some of that extra twine into a ball. So he, of course, picked up the twine yelling at Harlan that he's just young and needs to start picking up at himself.
约翰逊家族的农场。伟大的弗朗西斯叔祖父和他巨大的麻绳球的故事就是从那里开始的。我很想告诉你，弗朗西斯·约翰逊当时有一个宏伟的愿景，要滚动全国见过的最大的麻绳球。但事实是，他只是手头有太多的麻绳。约翰逊是个农民，他的农场，实际上所有的农场都一样，到处都是麻绳。1950年的一天，在清理完他侄子哈兰留下的烂摊子后，约翰逊开始把那些多余的麻绳卷成一个球。当然，他捡起麻绳，冲着哈兰大喊，说他还年轻，需要开始自己收拾东西。
Well, before you know it, he had, you know, a six inch twine ball. Well, the six inch twine ball will get into a foot. And for reasons unknown, even to himself, Johnson rolled that ball a twine for the next 29 years. The twine ball was easy enough to roll in its early stages. Johnson would work on it in the basement, but as it got bigger, he had to move the ball outside or it gets stuck down there for good. Here's an interview with Johnson from an early 80s TV show called Real People. I had to roll it out of the basement
好吧，不知不觉中，他就有了一个六英寸大的麻绳球。嗯，六英寸的麻绳球会变成一英尺。出于连他自己都不知道的原因，约翰逊在接下来的29年里一直滚动着那个麻绳球。麻绳球在早期阶段很容易滚动。约翰逊会在地下室里加工它，但随着它变得越来越大，他不得不把球移到外面，否则它就会永远卡在那里。这是一段约翰逊在80年代初电视节目《真人》中的采访。我不得不把它从地下室滚出来
while I could still get it through a 30 inch door and it's been out doors ever since. And it was outdoors on his front lawn that he rolled it for four hours a day every single day. It became an addiction and obsession and it was something that he wanted to do because it sparked something inside of him. Francis Johnson was a perfectionist and he was adamant that his twine ball should be a perfectly round sphere.
趁我还能把它通过30英寸的门，从那以后它就一直放在户外。就是在前草坪的户外，他每天都要滚动它四个小时。这成了一种瘾，一种痴迷，这是他想做的事情，因为它点燃了他内心的某种东西。弗朗西斯·约翰逊是个完美主义者，他坚持认为他的麻绳球应该是一个完美的球体。
As it got bigger, he rolled it around the yard to make sure he added twine evenly, so it remained beautifully symmetrical. But eventually, the ball got so big that he couldn't roll it around his yard anymore with just his body weight. And so Johnson invented an ingenious method to rotate the ball using railroad jacks. He would tuck a jack under the ball and use it to nudge the ball forward. And then the twine ball would roll. And of course on the other side of it he would have something to stop the ball from rolling
随着它变大，他把它在院子里滚来滚去，以确保他均匀地添加麻绳，这样它就能保持完美的对称。但最终，球变得太大了，他仅靠自己的体重已经无法在院子里滚动它了。于是，约翰逊发明了一种巧妙的方法，利用铁路千斤顶来旋转球。他会把千斤顶塞在球下面，用它来推动球向前。然后麻绳球就会滚动。当然，在它的另一边，他会放一些东西来阻止球滚动
completely. He repeated this process over and over. Rolling the ball, adding twine, rolling the ball, adding more twine. He rolled it around his yard, he chained it to a tree, so no one would steal the twine ball. I mean, who would steal the twine ball, but that was the way he was. The ball attracted a lot of attention both in and out of Darwin.
完全滚走。他一遍又一遍地重复这个过程。滚动球，添加麻绳，滚动球，添加更多的麻绳。他在院子里滚动它，把它锁在树上，这样就不会有人偷走麻绳球。我是说，谁会偷麻绳球呢，但他就是那样的人。这个球在达尔文内外都引起了极大的关注。
It appeared on television, got written about newspapers, and Weirdau would eventually write a song about it. The ball had made Johnson famous, even if he wasn't willing to admit it. The ball had made Johnson famous, even if he wasn't willing to admit it. Well, I don't know about that. About being famous, I have other modest little guy from the schick. They got to take me this I have. Francis' twine ball was absolutely massive. It had to be the largest ball of twine in the
它出现在电视上，被写进报纸，怪人奥尔最终还为它写了一首歌。这个球让约翰逊出了名，即使他不愿承认。这个球让约翰逊出了名，即使他不愿承认。嗯，我不知道。关于出名，我只是个来自小地方的谦虚小人物。他们非要这么说，我有什么办法。弗朗西斯的麻绳球确实非常巨大。它一定是世界上最大的麻绳球。
world. So that's what he called it. This is the biggest ball of twine in the world because there's no one to come for it for the bigger one. Until someone dead. I'm Linda Clover. I live in Cochars City, Kansas, and I'm the caretaker of the world's largest ball of twine. Cochars City is about 500 miles south of Darwin. They too have a massive ball of twine, and it's Linda's job to look after it. The Wall Street Journal called me the bell of the ball, but to some local people, I think I'm the crazy
世界。所以他就是这么称呼它的。这是世界上最大的麻绳球，因为没有人能做出更大的了。直到有人真的做到了。我是琳达·克洛弗。我住在堪萨斯州的考克市，我是世界上最大的麻绳球的看管人。考克市在达尔文以南约500英里处。他们也有一个巨大的麻绳球，照顾它是琳达的工作。《华尔街日报》称我为“球中美人”，但对一些当地人来说，我想我是那个疯狂的
twine lady. Cochars City's population is a little larger than Darwin's, but walking around you wouldn't guess it. It almost felt like an empty set of a western movie. And in some of the windows of the abandoned storefronts, there's twine ball inspired artwork, the Mona Lisa holding a twine ball, and one of Georgia O'Keefe's flowers with the twine ball at the center. We have things going on, but not much, but that's okay. We have beautiful sunrises and sunsets
麻绳女士。考克市的人口比达尔文稍微多一点，但走在街上你感觉不到。它几乎感觉像是一个西部电影的空置片场。在一些废弃店面的窗户里，有一些受麻绳球启发的艺术品，比如拿着麻绳球的蒙娜丽莎，还有乔治亚·欧姬芙的花朵，中间放着麻绳球。我们这里有活动，但不多，不过没关系。我们有美丽的日出和日落
and the wonderful lake. They also have an absolutely gigantic twine ball sitting under an open air gazebo right in the center of town. And unlike its counterpart in Darwin, which is trapped behind glass, this one you can walk right up to in touch. We want people to be able to smell it, because twine has its own fragrance. It certainly does.
还有美妙的湖泊。他们还有一个巨大的麻绳球，放在镇中心的一个露天凉亭下。与达尔文那个被困在玻璃后面的球不同，这个球你可以直接走过去触摸。我们希望人们能够闻到它，因为麻绳有它自己独特的香味。确实如此。
Ooh, it's got a smell. Ooh, it smells moist. Linda Clover may be the caretaker of the Cocker City twine ball, but it was rolled by a man named Frank Stober. Stober started in 1953, coincidentally right around the same time that Johnson was getting going up in Minnesota. Amazingly, two men about the same time, one in Minnesota and one man from Kansas, did twine balls.
噢，它有味道。噢，闻起来潮潮的。琳达·克洛弗可能是考克市麻绳球的看管人，但它是弗兰克·斯托伯滚动出来的。斯托伯在1953年开始，巧合的是，这大约和约翰逊在明尼苏达州开始的时间差不多。令人惊奇的是，两个男人在同一时间，一个在明尼苏达州，一个在堪萨斯州，都制作了麻绳球。
Stober was a farmer, just like Francis Johnson, and he got started rolling his ball of twine in basically the exact same way that Johnson did. He started it because he was cleaning up his barn, and the man just was picking up the twine because it was on his barn floor, thinking he would roll it into a ball, put it into a tub, to get it out of the way. Stober and Johnson were both raised with a depression error reluctance to waste anything at all.
斯托伯和弗朗西斯·约翰逊一样是个农民，他开始滚动麻绳球的方式基本上和约翰逊一模一样。他开始这样做是因为他在清理他的谷仓，他只是捡起地上的麻绳，因为它们在谷仓地板上，想着把它们卷成一个球，放进桶里，以免碍事。斯托伯和约翰逊都是在经济大萧条时期长大的，有一种不浪费任何东西的习惯。
Except for time. And Stobler may not have been the first person to try to roll the world's biggest twineball, but he certainly had a talent for it. By 1956, just three years in, Stobler's ball was already seven and a half feet tall and weighed over four thousand pounds, nearly the size of the Darwin twine ball. I think it starts with people maybe making fun of them because it's such a ludicrous thing,
除了时间。斯托伯可能不是第一个尝试滚动世界上最大的麻绳球的人，但他确实有这方面的天赋。到1956年，仅仅三年时间，斯托伯的球就已经有七英尺半高，重达四千多磅，几乎和达尔文的麻绳球一样大。我想这始于人们可能在嘲笑他们，因为这是一件如此荒谬的事情，
but then you quickly realize there's something about them that, you know, it's somebody who took what should have been insignificant little pieces of twine or string or garbage, and they'd made something that's essentially made them immortal. This is Doug Kirby,
但随后你很快就会意识到，关于他们有一些东西，你知道，这是一个把本应微不足道的麻绳、细绳或垃圾变成某种东西的人，这本质上让他们变得不朽。这是道格·柯比，
the co-founder of Roadside America, which is a website dedicated to documenting the quirky, kooky, and kitschy roadside attractions along our highways. The balls are pretty much a pilgrimage site for different groups now because you really can't go through Minnesota or Kansas and not detour to see those balls. Kirby's been tracking the status of the balls for a long time. And when I went to meet with him, he even sketched out a little cartoon timeline for me. He says that for a stretch of time,
“路边美国”的联合创始人，这是一个致力于记录我们高速公路沿线古怪、疯狂和媚俗的路边景点的网站。这些球现在几乎成了不同群体的朝圣地，因为你真的不能穿过明尼苏达州或堪萨斯州而不绕道去看看那些球。柯比长期以来一直在追踪这些球的状态。当我见到他时，他甚至为我画了一个小卡通时间轴。他说，有一段时间，
it looked like Stobber's Ball and Cawker City might have taken the lead. There's no record and we have our speculation on the website, which was that Cawker City's hit 11 feet and 8.61. By this point, Stobber's Ball had become a popular attraction in Central Kansas. He would take it to local fairs and people would try to guess the weight. It was such a hit that town officials asked Stober if he could bring the twine ball into the town to put it on permanent display. And then finally, after decades of speculation,
看起来斯托伯的球和考克市的球可能领先了。没有记录，我们在网站上有我们的推测，那就是考克市的球达到了11英尺8.61英寸。到这个时候，斯托伯的球已经成为堪萨斯州中部的一个热门景点。他会把它带到当地的集市上，人们会尝试猜测它的重量。它太受欢迎了，以至于镇政府官员问斯托伯是否可以把麻绳球带进镇里进行永久展示。然后终于，在几十年的猜测之后，
the world's largest ball of twine became official in pretty much the only way these sorts of things can. Yes, it was in the Guinness Book of World Records. Officials from the Guinness Book of World Records came to Cawker City, Kansas in 1973. And declared Stoper's Ball, the official world's largest ball of twine at 11 feet in diameter. Unfortunately, his glory was short-lived because he died the following year in 1974. Meanwhile, up in Darwin, Minnesota, Johnson was still alive and kicking and rolling twine. He kept going until he surpassed Dauber's Ball and dethroned Cawker City for the Guinness World record just a few years later.
世界上最大的麻绳球以这种事情几乎唯一可能的方式变得正式了。是的，它被列入了《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》。《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》的官员于1973年来到堪萨斯州的考克市，宣布斯托伯的球为官方认定的世界上最大的麻绳球，直径为11英尺。不幸的是，他的荣耀很短暂，因为他在第二年，即1974年去世了。与此同时，在明尼苏达州的达尔文，约翰逊仍然活着，并且还在滚动麻绳。他一直坚持，直到几年后他超过了斯托伯的球，并从考克市手中夺回了吉尼斯世界纪录。
And without anyone left to challenge his place in history, Johnson retired from Twine Ball Rolling. He died 10 years later, from infosima at the age of 85. It was a lung disease that did kill him, and you look at family history. There is no history of it, so a lot of people say it was inhaling twine and chemicals and all that throughout those years that probably was the reason of his death. His family contends that Johnson's lifelong passion ultimately killed him. Yeah, but I don't think he'd change anything. If someone were to tell him, you know, you're gonna die from this, you'd be like, so, and you'd keep doing it. In the story could have ended there, with two dead twine men, the largest ball of twine in the world, and the second largest ball of twine in the world.
在没有人能挑战他在历史上的地位后，约翰逊从滚动麻绳球中退休了。10年后，他因肺气肿去世，享年85岁。这是一种肺部疾病夺走了他的生命，你看看家族病史。并没有这种病史，所以很多人说是因为那些年吸入了麻绳和化学物质，这很可能是他死亡的原因。他的家人认为约翰逊终身的激情最终杀死了他。是的，但我不认为他会改变任何事情。如果有人告诉他，你知道，你会因为这个而死，他会说，那又怎样，然后他会继续做下去。故事本可以在这里结束，有两个死去的麻绳人，世界上最大的麻绳球，和第二大的麻绳球。
But Cogercity wasn't finished yet. Stober had left the twine ball to the city after he died. And for a few years, it just sat there in the downtown gazebo, a tribute to the second greatest twine ball roller in history. But then the town decided they didn't want to settle for second best. We decided let's have some fun. And we started having what we call our annual Twineathon.
但考克市还没有结束。斯托伯去世后把麻绳球留给了这个城市。几年里，它就一直放在市中心的凉亭里，作为对历史上第二伟大的麻绳球滚动者的致敬。但后来镇上决定他们不想满足于第二名。我们决定找点乐子。于是我们开始举办所谓的年度“麻绳马拉松”。
Residents of Cawker City decided to jump in and start adding more twine to the Stobber Ball to see if they could beat the record again. But this time, it wouldn't be the product of one man, but an entire community. The town had what was a brilliant idea, which was let's let the community keep rolling in. Here's Doug Kirby from Roadside America again. He says that Cocker City started holding twineathons once a year, where everyone in town would
考克市的居民决定加入并开始向斯托伯的球添加更多的麻绳，看看他们是否能再次打破纪录。但这一次，它不会是一个人的产物，而是一个整个社区的产物。镇上有一个绝妙的主意，那就是让社区继续滚动它。这是“路边美国”的道格·柯比。他说考克市开始每年举办一次麻绳马拉松，镇上的每个人都会
gather to help grow the twine ball. And eventually, they started allowing visitors to wrap the twine ball. And eventually they started allowing visitors to wrap the twine ball on a daily basis. Getting to wrap the twine ball became the reason to visit Cawker City. So whether it was townspeople or visitors and let's just have the ball set up so that the spool is ready, you can add to the ball, you'll see immediately that you're adding to this world record. So it's a different approach. Linda Clover literally keeps spools of twine on her at all times, on the off chance that she runs into someone who wants to add to the ball.
聚集在一起帮助麻绳球长大。最终，他们开始允许游客包裹麻绳球。最终他们开始允许游客每天包裹麻绳球。去包裹麻绳球成了访问考克市的理由。所以无论是镇民还是游客，我们只是把球设置好，让线轴准备好，你可以添加到球上，你会立即看到你正在为这个世界纪录做出贡献。所以这是一种不同的方法。琳达·克洛弗确实随时随地都带着麻绳线轴，以防她遇到想给球添加麻绳的人。
If you go to my car or my pickup truck, either one has twine that I have ready to let people add twine onto the ball. Now no one else in town carries twine with them, but Linda Clover does. With so many people participating, the Cocker City Ball continues to grow bigger and bigger. The latest estimate has it at 20,500 pounds, over 2,500 pounds heavier than Johnson's. And when you see it in person, it's unquestionably larger in circumference. But not everyone agrees that rolling twine balls
如果你去我的车或皮卡车，任何一辆都有我准备好的麻绳，让人们可以把麻绳加到球上。现在镇上没有其他人随身携带麻绳，但琳达·克洛弗有。随着这么多人的参与，考克市的球变得越来越大。最新的估计是20,500磅，比约翰逊的重了2,500多磅。当你亲眼看到它时，它的周长无疑更大。但并不是每个人都同意滚动麻绳球
should be a group project, especially in Darwin. Courtney says that Johnson's ball is particularly impressive, not just because of its perfectly round shape, but because it was the sole accomplishment of one man. It needed to be done by him because it needed to be perfect, it needed to be solid, it needed to be done with only a certain type of twine, you know, he was just so particular, it needed things done by himself. And remember Johnson had his own special technique for rolling a perfectly symmetrical
应该是一个集体项目，尤其是在达尔文。考特尼说，约翰逊的球特别令人印象深刻，不仅因为它的形状非常圆，还因为它是一个人的唯一成就。它需要由他来完成，因为它需要完美，它需要坚固，它需要只用某种特定的麻绳来完成，你知道，他就是那么挑剔，它需要由他自己来完成。记住，约翰逊有他自己滚动完美对称球体的特殊技术。
sphere. The people of Cocharsity don't have that. They have no way to wrap the top and the bottom of the ball so it just keeps getting wider and wider. In fact, it's not really a ball anymore, more an oval with a flat bottom. So Cocharsity's ball might be bigger, but the Darwin ball is definitely nicer to look at. Darwin is by far my favorite ball. This is Edward Meyer, and he's currently retired, but up until a year ago, he had probably the coolest job I'd ever heard of. My primary focus was to buy exhibits to put in the museums,
考克市的人没有那个。他们没有办法包裹球的顶部和底部，所以它只会变得越来越宽。事实上，它不再是一个球了，更像是一个底部平坦的椭圆形。所以考克市的球可能更大，但达尔文的球绝对更好看。达尔文是我最喜欢的球。这是爱德华·迈耶，他目前已经退休，但在一年之前，他可能拥有我听说过的最酷的工作。我的主要工作是购买展品放入博物馆，
which Ripley's calls Auditorium, spelled ODD, around the world. Meyer was vice president of exhibits and archives with Ripley's believe it or not, meaning it was literally his job to find the weirdest things in the world and put them on display. And back in the early 90s, he had his eye on Darwin's giant twine ball.
雷普利称之为“奇闻馆”，拼写为ODD，遍布世界各地。迈耶是雷普利“信不信由你”的展品和档案副总裁，这意味着他的工作实际上就是寻找世界上最奇怪的东西并把它们展示出来。早在90年代初，他就盯上了达尔文的巨型麻绳球。
The Darwin ball, you know, it's almost romantic. It's one man's dream and it takes him a long time and he has certain rules that he plays by and doesn't break. And, you know, it's, you know, I'm getting silly, I guess. But, you know, it's, you know, I'm getting silly, I guess, but you know, it's an accomplishment like climbing Everest. Meyer had been interested in the Darwin twine ball for years, and his luck would have it. Johnson's nephew had inherited his entire estate, including the twine ball.
达尔文的球，你知道，它几乎是浪漫的。这是一个人的梦想，它花了他很长时间，他有他遵守的某些规则，并且不会打破。而且，你知道，我变得有点傻了，我想。但是，你知道，这是一个像攀登珠穆朗玛峰一样的成就。迈耶多年来一直对达尔文的麻绳球很感兴趣，幸运的是。约翰逊的侄子继承了他的全部遗产，包括麻绳球。
Johnson's nephew called Meyer up one day to ask if he wanted to come to Darwin and possibly purchased the ball for Ripley's. He invited me and I said, sure, I'd love to come. Meyer was asked to pitch the town on the idea of putting Johnson's twine ball in a Ripley's museum. And personally, he thought what better way to honor Johnson's accomplishment than to put it on display where possibly thousands of people a week would see it. I gave a presentation were possibly thousands of people a week would see it. I gave a presentation and told them that I wanted to buy it and the reaction was, you know, over our dead body.
约翰逊的侄子有一天打电话给迈耶，问他是否想来达尔文，并可能为雷普利购买这个球。他邀请了我，我说，当然，我很乐意去。迈耶被要求向镇上推销把约翰逊的麻绳球放进雷普利博物馆的想法。他个人认为，还有什么比把它展示出来，让每周可能有成千上万的人看到它，更能纪念约翰逊的成就呢？我做了一个演讲，
It was probably one of the most uncomfortable evenings of my entire life. I was literally in fear of my life. I was not sure how this was going to end. Spoiler alert. He wasn't murdered by a mob of angry townspeople, but they were pretty upset. For one, the people of Darwin thought the Twine Ball could bring in tourism to the area.
告诉他们我想买它，反应是，你知道，除非我们死了。这可能是我一生中最不舒服的夜晚之一。我真的担心我的生命安全。我不确定这会如何结束。剧透警告。他没有被一群愤怒的镇民谋杀，但他们确实非常生气。首先，达尔文的人民认为麻绳球可以为该地区带来旅游业。
But more importantly, the ball had become part of Darwin's identity. Twine Ball is a good analogy, we say it's. The twine that binds, it represents,. It represents not only how we support that, but our support of each other. This is Josh Johnson, the mayor of Darwin. The town had adopted the ball as their own so much so that they even started an annual tradition
但更重要的是，这个球已经成为达尔文身份的一部分。麻绳球是一个很好的类比，我们说它是。连接的麻绳，它代表。它不仅代表了我们如何支持这一点，还代表了我们对彼此的支持。这是达尔文市长乔什·约翰逊。镇上已经把这个球当作他们自己的东西，以至于他们甚至开始了一个年度传统
called Darwin Twineball Day, which includes a number of twineball-related activities, like a twine K, which is kind of like a 5K. It starts out with a 17,400 foot run. That's a 17,400 foot run to celebrate a 17,400 pound twine ball. They pass out candy to kids, roll miniature versions of the twine ball down the street, and have a parade. It probably lasts around 35 minutes, which is the right length for a parade these days, in my opinion. Francis Johnson's ball had become central to life in Darwin.
叫达尔文麻绳球日，其中包括许多与麻绳球相关的活动，比如“麻绳5K”，这有点像5公里跑。它以17,400英尺的跑步开始。那是一场17,400英尺的跑步，为了庆祝一个17,400磅的麻绳球。他们给孩子们分发糖果，把麻绳球的微型版本滚下街，并举行游行。它可能持续大约35分钟，在我看来，这对游行来说是合适的长度。弗朗西斯·约翰逊的球已经成为达尔文生活的核心。
And Darwin made it clear that if Meyer wanted a giant twine ball for Ripley's, he would have to get it from some other town. And that's exactly what Edward Meyer did. Well, I literally read it in an airplane magazine that this guy in Texas had been inspired as much by Cawker City as he had been by Darwin. As it turned out, while Darwin and Cawker City were battling it out in their public twine ball arms race, a third ball was rapidly growing in Texas at the hands of a man named JC Payne. Payne was a retired brick Mason, who was the type of guy
达尔文明确表示，如果迈耶想要一个巨大的麻绳球给雷普利，他必须从其他城镇获得。而这正是爱德华·迈耶所做的。好吧，我确实在飞机杂志上读到，德克萨斯州的这个家伙受到考克市的启发，就像他受到达尔文的启发一样。事实证明，当达尔文和考克市在他们的公共麻绳球军备竞赛中争斗时，第三个球在德克萨斯州由一个叫JC·佩恩的人手中迅速成长。佩恩是一位退休的砖瓦匠，他是那种
who was always in search of a new project. And in the late 1980s, he found one. Payne had read about the Battle of the Balls in Darwin and Cawker City and had a clear favorite in the race. From the beginning, JC Payne did not want Cawker City to meet Frances Johnson. Apparently, Payne was not a fan of the fact that the Corker City community effort was about to beat Johnson's solo project.
总是寻找新项目的人。在1980年代末，他找到了一个。佩恩读过关于达尔文和考克市的球赛，在比赛中有一个明确的最爱。从一开始，JC·佩恩就不希望考克市超过弗朗西斯·约翰逊。显然，佩恩不喜欢考克市的社区努力即将击败约翰逊的个人项目这一事实。
Pain believed in the great man theory of toy ball rolling. He thought that it was a shame that Corker City was going to soon be bigger than Darwin's because the whole town was involved in it. He thought that this was, you know, I used the word cheating, but that's, you know, my interpretation and said, you know, if Francis isn't going to be the world's biggest, then I'm going to be the world's biggest. Paintings start rolling his ball until 1987, a full 37 years after Johnson. But by 1992,
佩恩相信伟人理论的球滚动。他认为考克市很快就会比达尔文大，因为整个城镇都参与其中，这是一种耻辱。他认为这是，你知道，我用了“作弊”这个词，但那是，你知道，我的解释，并说，你知道，如果弗朗西斯不是世界最大的，那么我就是世界最大的。佩恩直到1987年才开始滚动他的球，比约翰逊晚了整整37年。但到1992年，
the Guinness Book of World Records declared it the largest ball in the world. In a few short years, pain managed to create a ball that was 42 feet in circumference, 13 feet tall, and weighed six tons. Part of it is that he had a tool, used technology to add the string to it. He had a tractor, he had a hook type implement that
《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》宣布它是世界上最大的球。在短短几年内，佩恩设法创造了一个周长42英尺、高13英尺、重6吨的球。部分原因是由于他有一个工具，利用技术把绳子加到上面。他有一台拖拉机，他有一个钩子类型的工具，
prevented him from getting his hands wrecked that he wasn't literally even touching it at some point. Part of it was that he used whatever he could get in terms of string nylon specifically, which bothered a lot of twine ball purists who like to think of twine in the more traditional, more natural sense. I've seen the pile of plastic.
防止他的手被毁掉，他在某种程度上甚至没有真正触摸它。部分原因是由于他使用了他能得到的任何绳子，特别是尼龙，这困扰了许多喜欢以更传统、更自然的方式思考麻绳的麻绳球纯粹主义者。我见过那堆塑料。
Here's Linda Clover from Cocker City again. They're complete. We're talking apples and oranges. You know, complete and something completely different. The main gripe about JC Payne's ball was that he used artificial colored nylon twine, while Johnson and Stober both used sisal twine. Sisal is an earthy colored plant-based material and has that classic farm look. Whereas nylon just looks like city-slicker twine.
这是考克市的琳达·克洛弗。它们是完整的。我们谈论的是苹果和橘子。你知道，完全是两码事。对JC·佩恩的球的主要抱怨是他使用了人造彩色尼龙绳，而约翰逊和斯托伯都使用了剑麻绳。剑麻是一种土色植物基材料，具有经典的农场外观。而尼龙看起来就像城市里的花哨绳子。
Nylon also weighs less, making paintball much lighter than both cocker city and Darwin's. The end result was a multicolored artificial lighter weight monstrosity. An Edward Meyer from Ripley's had to have it. was a multi-colored artificial later weight monstrosity. An Edward Meyer from Ripley's had to have it. My buying it was a backhanded, you know, all by this because, you know, I missed out the one I really wanted, but I can still get one. So he flew to Valleyview, Texas to meet pain in person and see the ball for himself.
尼龙的重量也更轻，使得佩恩的球比考克市和达尔文的球轻得多。最终的结果是一个多色的、人造的、重量较轻的怪物。而雷普利的爱德华·迈耶必须拥有它。是一个多色的、人造的、重量较轻的怪物。而雷普利的爱德华·迈耶必须拥有它。我买它是一种反讽，你知道，我买了它，因为，你知道，我错过了我真正想要的那个，但我仍然可以得到一个。所以他飞往德克萨斯州的瓦利维尤亲自见佩恩，并亲自看看这个球。
Nice man, salt to the earth, a little bit on the competitive side. But, you know, just a basic farm type guy. And his ball, when I first saw it, looked pretty darn good. But it didn't look good for long. Pretty soon, they realized that they'd have to move this six-ton ball
好人，脚踏实地，有点竞争心。但是，你知道，只是一个基本的农场类型的人。他的球，当我第一次看到它时，看起来相当不错。但它并没有好太久。很快，他们意识到他们必须移动这个六吨重的球
to a new Ripley's Museum being built in Branson, Missouri. Well, we dragged it out of the barn and that messed it up a little bit and then we had to lift it by a crane which messed it up more and then it was dropped onto a flatbed truck that flattened the bottom part of it. And then it was driven, you know, the roughly thousand miles to Branson, Missouri from Denton, Texas. Still, this misshapen monster of a ball was going to be the piester resistance of the new Ripley's museum. And the ball was so huge that the building had to be constructed around
到正在密苏里州布兰森建造的新雷普利博物馆。好吧，我们把它从谷仓里拖出来，这弄坏了一点，然后我们不得不把它用起重机吊起来，这弄坏得更多，然后它被扔到了一辆平板卡车上，压扁了它的底部。然后它被驾驶，你知道，大约一千英里从德克萨斯州的丹顿到密苏里州的布兰森。尽管如此，这个畸形的怪物球将成为新雷普利博物馆的压轴戏。而且这个球太大了，建筑物必须围绕它建造。
it. If for any reason they ever need to move it out of there, they'll either need to take the roof off or blast a hole in the wall. Oh wow, so cool. Yeah, it's huge. I went to see Paine's twine ball for myself at the Ripley's in Branson. In person, it's a little blobby looking, like a ball of cookie dough that's been sitting out for too long, and it's comprised of shiny nylon strands every color of the rainbow.
如果因为任何原因他们需要把它移出那里，他们要么需要拆掉屋顶，要么在墙上炸一个洞。哦哇，太酷了。是的，它太大了。我亲自去布兰森的雷普利看了佩恩的麻绳球。亲眼看，它看起来有点像一团球，就像一团放得太久的饼干面团，它由彩虹色的闪亮尼龙线组成。
It's pretty impressive, but it sits on display between an ornate miniature palace carved out of camel bone, and a six-foot ship made entirely of jade. And honestly, both are so beautiful that they make the ball look a little pedestrian. Not to mention something else I noticed. So I'm just noticing something right now, which is that on this sign, it doesn't say the world's largest twine ball. It says world largest string ball. So it's not even technically designated as twine here at
它非常令人印象深刻，但它陈列在一个用骆驼骨雕刻的华丽微型宫殿和一个完全由玉石制成的六英尺船之间。老实说，两者都太美了，以至于它们让这个球看起来有点平庸。更不用说我注意到的另一件事了。所以我现在注意到一件事，那就是在这个标志上，它没有写“世界上最大的麻绳球”。它写的是“世界最大的绳球”。所以它在这里甚至没有被技术性地指定为麻绳
Ripley's. And this might be why the great American twine ball contest or string ball contest is never going to get a satisfying clear-cut winner because no one is ever going to agree on the rules of the contest. But at this point, all of the contestants seem to be okay with the version of the story where everyone wins. Each town has the largest twine ball, depending on what you mean by that. Darwin's is the largest twine ball rolled by one man. Cocker cities is the largest ball of sysil twine, and JC Payne's is the largest nylon string ball.
雷普利。这可能就是为什么伟大的美国麻绳球比赛或绳球比赛永远不会有一个令人满意的明确赢家的原因，因为没有人会同意比赛的规则。但在这一点上，所有的参赛者似乎都对每个人都赢的故事版本感到满意。每个城镇都有最大的麻绳球，取决于你对它的定义。达尔文的是由一个人滚动出的最大的麻绳球。考克市的是最大的剑麻绳球，而JC·佩恩的是最大的尼龙绳球。
It's a three-way truce. Except... Hi! JFK? Hi! Is there a cape we come over? This is... This is very impressive.
这是一个三方休战。除了……嗨！JFK？嗨！有斗篷我们可以过来吗？这是……这非常令人印象深刻。
This is the biggest ball that've seen in the world. Of course it is. Yep, there's a fourth ball. And this one is in the Northwoods of Wisconsin. The man who's rolling it is named James Franco Terra, but he prefers to go by JFK. I visited him at the end of my road trip, and he doesn't talk a whole lot, but he has
这是我见过的世界上最大的球。当然是。是的，有第四个球。这个在威斯康星州的北林地。滚动它的男人叫詹姆斯·弗兰科·泰拉，但他更喜欢被称为JFK。我在公路旅行结束时拜访了他，他话不多，但他有
handmade signs posted all over his property with the story of his ball. He writes that one night, in 1975, God came to him and told him that he was going to stop drinking, turn his life around, and become the world famous twine man. And that's more or less what he did. Does anybody help you with it? No, no. No, no. No one ever helps you. Just one person. That's J.F.K. And J.F.K's ball is a little different from the rest. He takes small segments of colorful twine and weaves and tucks the individual pieces into the ball. So the surface resembles
手工制作的标志贴在他的财产各处，上面写着他球的故事。他写道，1975年的一天晚上，上帝来到他身边，告诉他他要戒酒，改变生活，成为世界著名的麻绳人。这或多或少就是他所做的。有人帮你吗？不，不。不，不。从来没有人帮你。只有一个人。那是JFK。JFK的球和其他球有点不同。他取小段彩色麻绳，把单独的碎片编织并塞进球里。所以表面看起来像
a net. It's also a lot harder for him to reach the top, so the ball's a lot wider than it is tall. It almost looks like a modern art sculpture, or a multi-colored fun-feddy potato. J.F.K. claims that his ball is the largest by using a different metric. Wait. largest by using a different metric. Wait. 23,375 pounds. J.F.K thinks that his ball is about 23,375 pounds based on his calculations. Nearly 3,000 pounds heavier than Cawker cities. He says he knows this because before adding twine to the ball,
一个网。他也很难够到顶部，所以球比它高要宽得多。它看起来几乎像一个现代艺术雕塑，或者一个多色的fun-feddy土豆。JFK声称他的球是最大的，使用不同的度量标准。等等。使用不同的度量标准是最大的。等等。23,375磅。JFK认为他的球大约是23,375磅，基于他的计算。比考克市的重了近3,000磅。他说他知道这一点，因为在给球添加麻绳之前，
he puts it in a garbage bag, weighs it, and then adds the total to his overall measurements. If he's correct, his is definitely the heaviest of the four twine balls. But JFK is not looking for official records. He doesn't need some outsider to come in and tell him what he already believes. Have you heard of the Guinness Book of World Records? Are you interested in having them come to measure it at all? No, no, I do it myself. So you don't really care about what they have to say.
他把它放在垃圾袋里，称重，然后把总数加到他的整体测量中。如果他是对的，他的绝对是四个麻绳球中最重的。但JFK并不寻求官方记录。他不需要外人进来告诉他他已经相信的事情。你听说过《吉尼斯世界纪录大全》吗？你有兴趣让他们来测量一下吗？不，不，我自己做。所以你真的不在乎他们怎么说。
This is mine, mine. This is just for you. Right. So for now, a careful balance is intact. The four largest twine balls exist peacefully, alongside one another. Each content with their own version of superiority. Because there are so many ways to have the biggest ball of something, like the largest ball of stamps in Boyz Town, Nebraska, or the largest ball of VHS tape in Kansas City,
这是我的，我的。这只是给你的。对。所以现在，一个谨慎的平衡是完整的。四个最大的麻绳球和平地共存。每个人都满足于他们自己版本的优越感。因为有很多方法可以拥有最大的球，比如内布拉斯加州博伊斯镇最大的邮票球，或者堪萨斯城最大的VHS磁带球，
or the World's Largest Disco ball in the UK. Let it go, Vivian. But what about the World's Largest Ball of Pain in Indiana? It's time to come home. I talked to Vivian about other roadside attractions on her death-define Midwestern tour after this. So I'm back in the studio with Vivian Lee and in addition to seeing many many balls of twine, when we were following along, we were deeply concerned about your safety and well-being. I was actually very concerned about my safety and well-being.
或者英国世界上最大的迪斯科球。放手吧，薇薇安。但是印第安纳州世界上最大的痛苦球呢？是时候回家了。在这之后，我和薇薇安谈了她在中西部死亡挑战之旅中的其他路边景点。所以我回到了演播室，和薇薇安·李在一起，除了看到许多许多麻绳球，当我们跟随的时候，我们非常担心你的安全和健康。我实际上非常担心我的安全和健康。
I was actually very concerned about my safety and well-being at the same time. And it's not because of twine, it was because of the weather. Yeah, so apparently, if you're going to plan a reporting trip to a part of the country called Tornado Alley, you should probably check when Tornado season is, because I happen to be there during the peak of tornado season and there was the most tornado activity. Yeah. Of like since like 2011 or 12 or something.
我当时也确实非常担心我的安全和健康。这不是因为麻绳，而是因为天气。是的，所以显然，如果你要计划一次去该国被称为“龙卷风走廊”的地区的报道旅行，你可能应该检查龙卷风季节是什么时候，因为我碰巧在龙卷风季节的高峰期在那里，而且龙卷风活动最多。是的。自2011年或12年左右以来的那种。
So that was- So yeah, so tornadoes were landing all around you. Yeah, I was- You didn't see a tornado. I did not see a tornado. I had three weather apps on my phone open at all times and I was tracking the storm and being the exact opposite of Bill Paxton
所以那是——所以是的，所以龙卷风在你周围着陆。是的，我——你没有看到龙卷风。我没有看到龙卷风。我的手机上一直开着三个天气应用程序，我正在追踪风暴，并且是电影《龙卷风》中比尔·帕克斯顿的完全相反，
in the movie Twister, so I would like track the storm and then go as fast as I can, the opposite direction. But it was a bummer because I've never been in this part of the country before, so I can make a list of all these roadside attractions that I wanted to see along the way. So I really wanted to see the Frank Lloyd Wright gas station in Minnesota.
所以我想追踪风暴，然后尽可能快地向相反的方向走。但这很扫兴，因为我以前从未去过该国的这个地区，所以我可以列出所有我想在沿途看到的路边景点。所以我真的很想看明尼苏达州的弗兰克·劳埃德·赖特加油站。
Yeah. And yeah, and I wanted to see like the world's biggest banjo, but I just could, I was like rushing from place to place to try to just seek out shots at the entire time because there's thunderstorms and wind and it was terrifying. But one of the places that I really, really wanted to see, but just could not get to in time. It was in Lucas, Kansas, and it's called the world's largest collection of the smallest versions of the world's largest things. Okay, you said the world's largest collection of the smallest versions of the world's largest things. And it takes a second to really understand, but like everything you need is in the title.
是的。是的，我想看像世界上最大的班卓琴，但我只是可以，我当时在从一个地方赶到另一个地方，试图在整个时间内寻求拍摄，因为有雷暴和风，这很可怕。但我真的很想看，但就是没能及时赶到的地方之一。它在堪萨斯州的卢卡斯，它被称为“世界上最大的最小版本世界最大事物的集合”。好的，你说“世界上最大的最小版本世界最大事物的集合”。这需要一点时间才能真正理解，但就像你需要的一切都在标题里一样。
Yeah. So there's all these, there's a lot of different types of roadside attractions, but probably the most popular in the biggest category is like world's largest things. Right, right. So this is basically a collection of miniaturized versions of all the world's largest things in the country. Mm-hmm.
是的。所以有所有这些，有很多不同类型的路边景点，但可能最大的类别中最受欢迎的是像“世界最大事物”。对，对。所以这基本上是该国所有世界最大事物的微型版本集合。嗯。
So there's probably around 400 in the United States. And this woman named Eric Nelson has been basically traveling around and making small versions of all the world's largest roadside attractions that she's seen. And she's an independent artist and educator in Lucas Kansas.
所以在美国可能有大约400个。这个叫埃里克·尼尔森的女人基本上一直在旅行，并制作了她所见过的所有世界最大路边景点的微型版本。她是堪萨斯州卢卡斯的一名独立艺术家和教育家。
So I was like so fascinated by this that I decided to call her and ask her a little bit about how it works. I go to a world's largest thing, photograph it, gather its background story, then I make a world's smallest version of that world's largest thing and add it to my collection. And since I've been doing this for 15 years now, I now have the world's largest collection of those world's smallest versions have the world's largest collection of those world's smallest versions of the world's largest things. Oh my goodness.
所以我对此非常着迷，以至于我决定给她打电话，问她一点关于它是如何工作的。我去一个世界最大的事物，拍摄它，收集它的背景故事，然后我制作那个世界最大事物的世界最小版本，并把它加到我的收藏中。而且因为我已经这样做15年了，我现在拥有那些世界最大事物的世界最小版本的世界最大集合。我的天哪。
Oh, I like her. She's great. So why in the world that she started doing this? So she would visit these roadside attractions and a lot of times they wouldn't have a gift shop to bring home a souvenir. So she started making her own souvenirs in the form of these miniaturized versions of these world's largest things. Just for herself, like she just made her own thing.
哦，我喜欢她。她很棒。那么她为什么开始做这个呢？所以她会访问这些路边景点，很多时候他们没有礼品店可以带回家作为纪念品。所以她开始制作自己的纪念品，以这些世界最大事物的微型版本的形式。只是为了她自己，就像她只是制作了自己的东西。
Yeah, just to remember the trip by. Okay. So now she has, you know, over 200 miniatur in her collection and she's still doing it. She's still doing it. So she still goes to world's largest things and still makes new ones. Yeah, so she's hoping doing it. She's still doing it. So she still goes to world's largest things and still makes new ones. Yeah, so she's hoping to see all 400.
是的，只是为了记住这次旅行。好的。所以现在她有，你知道，超过200个微型在她的收藏中，她还在做。她还在做。所以她仍然去世界最大的事物，仍然制作新的。是的，所以她希望看到所有400个。
But she has a process where she goes. All 400, that's the number of world's largest things inside of America. It fluctuates. So there's always more popping up. And there's some that are just kind of disappearing from lack of care, or people just don't want to maintain them anymore.
但她有一个过程，她去。所有400个，那是美国内部世界最大事物的数量。它波动。所以总是有更多的涌现。有些只是因为缺乏照顾而消失，或者人们只是不想再维护它们了。
So Nelson has like a special affinity for the world's largest things, like these types of roadside attractions. But she's also fascinated with roadside attraction culture as a whole. And she was telling me that, if you look at it from a historical standpoint, you could see the ways in which infrastructure
所以尼尔森对世界最大的事物，像这些类型的路边景点有特殊的亲和力。但她也对整个路边景点文化着迷。她告诉我，如果你从历史的角度来看，你可以看到基础设施的方式
and a push towards car culture have created this environment for roadside attractions to really flourish. In the 1950s, 1960s, it was also not just our good roads policy, but this inner connectedness that we suddenly felt with our automobiles and that was really sold to us. This is how you get your own personal freedom is by having this machine that can take you as far as you're willing to take it. So all these little towns pops up in just the right distance
以及对汽车文化的推动，为路边景点的蓬勃发展创造了环境。在20世纪50年代和60年代，这不仅是因为我们的优质道路政策，还因为我们突然感受到了与汽车之间的内在联系，而这种联系被大力推销给我们。这就是你获得个人自由的方式，拥有一台能带你走多远就走多远的机器。于是，所有这些小城镇都在恰当的距离上涌现出来，
to fuel up again or get water again or use the bathroom again or sleep again. But then the interstate system kind of bypassed everything and all these small towns who had become dependent on slow travel were being bypassed. And I think those roadside attractions were that way to get people to stop again. So basically, if you don't need to stop in a town for gas or water or to use a bathroom, you have to create something for, you know, the reason why people stop, that's why you create the world's largest ball bungees that year.
以便再次加油、取水、上厕所或休息。但后来州际公路系统绕过了所有这些地方，那些依赖慢速旅行的小城镇被绕开了。我认为那些路边景点就是为了让人们再次停下来。所以基本上，如果你不需要在一个城镇停下来加油、取水或上厕所，你就必须创造一些东西，你知道，作为人们停下来的理由，这就是为什么你会在那一年创造出世界上最大的蹦极球。
Exactly. Yeah, I should. To pull people off the road. Yes, exactly. Like, if people, you'd normally just be completely bypassed. So it's just a way to keep your economy alive. I'm actually kind of curious about this world's largest phenomenon. Like, is this just an American thing that we like to make the largest thing possible? It does seem very distinctly American. Like, when I think of the world's largest ball of twine,
没错。是的，我应该这么做。为了把人们从路上吸引过来。是的，完全正确。就像，如果人们，你通常会被完全绕过。所以这只是保持经济活力的一种方式。我其实对这种“世界之最”的现象很好奇。这只是美国人的事吗？我们喜欢制造尽可能大的东西？这看起来确实非常有美国特色。就像，当我想到世界上最大的线团时，
I don't think I could think of anything more American than that. Right, and you don't think I'm gonna go to Switzerland to get the world's largest ball of twine. And our portion sizes are very big, so I would assume the same thing. But I actually asked Nelson about this. And she says it's not specifically like an American thing, but it's kind of like a new world countries thing.
我想不出比这更美国的东西了。没错，你不会认为我会去瑞士看世界上最大的线团。而且我们的份量很大，所以我也会有同样的假设。但我确实问过尼尔森这个问题。她说这并不是专门的美国现象，而是一种“新世界”国家的现象。
I think part of that love of superlatives does seem not just an American thing, but a very young country kind of thing. Because Australia and Canada also have that sort of need to make a mark because we're kind of lacking in that old, old, old history of our built environment because everybody who was here was much more in tune with nature and didn't make giant monuments to themselves. So once we started making our own history, we realized we don't have much.
我认为这种对最高级的热爱似乎不仅是美国人的事，而且是非常年轻的国家的一种特质。因为澳大利亚和加拿大也有那种想要留下印记的需求，因为我们缺乏那种古老、古老、古老的建筑环境历史，因为这里的人们更顺应自然，不会为自己建造巨大的纪念碑。所以当我们开始创造自己的历史时，我们意识到我们并没有多少东西。
So we started doing these superlative things to kind of loudmouth show off and say, hey, we're here. This is, look at our chicken. Oh my god, look at our chicken. So it's because we don't have something like the pantheon. We have So it's because we don't have something like the pantheon. We have the world's largest frying pan or something like that. Yes, just as good. It's the pantheon. What I think I like most about the world's largest collection of the smallest versions of the world's largest things as a project isn't just that it's a catalog of the biggest
所以我们开始做这些最高级的事情，有点像大声炫耀，说，嘿，我们在这儿。看，看看我们的鸡。天哪，看看我们的鸡。所以这是因为我们没有像万神殿那样的东西。我们有世界上最大的平底锅之类的东西。是的，一样好。这就是万神殿。关于“世界上最大的最小版本事物收藏”这个项目，我最喜欢的不仅仅是它是一个最大事物的目录，
things. It's also a way for Nelson to really explore the stories behind these small town monuments that aren't traditionally valued from an academic standpoint. Right, I mean, I guess there isn't the same sort of academic rigor applied to roadside attractions as there is other forms of vernacular architecture, but there's no reason why not. Yeah, exactly. Nelson actually says that this attitude is kind of shifting lately. I think there's a growing number of people who are who are taking them seriously and have
它也是尼尔森真正探索这些小城镇纪念碑背后故事的一种方式，这些纪念碑在学术上并不被传统地重视。没错，我的意思是，我想对路边景点的学术严谨性确实不如其他形式的乡土建筑，但没有理由不这样做。是的，完全正确。尼尔森实际上说这种态度最近正在转变。我认为越来越多的人开始认真对待它们，并且
had those debates since learning from Las Vegas came out and ended up being such a tone for architects. They address that very thing. When is, when is Kitch okay? When is populist architecture okay? And so with that introduction into scholarly debates, people started looking at them again. All of these things that they'd grown up around,
自从《向拉斯维加斯学习》出版并成为建筑师的重要参考书以来，人们就一直在进行这些辩论。他们解决了这个问题。什么时候媚俗是可以的？什么时候民粹主义建筑是可以的？随着这些进入学术辩论，人们开始重新审视它们。所有这些他们从小就熟悉的东西，
the built environment and re-evaluating them in the lenses that they were taught to look at more serious things. And we covered a lot of this stuff in a story Avery did about Denise Scott Brown and Robert Venturi about learning from Las Vegas. I mean, this idea that they became really advocates for the architecture of Las Vegas, that most people, and even people like I performed in Las Vegas for the AA conference and somebody wrote me to say, I can't believe we're doing it in Las Vegas.
这些建筑环境，并用他们被教导去审视更严肃事物的视角重新评估它们。我们在艾弗里关于丹妮丝·斯科特·布朗和罗伯特·文丘里关于《向拉斯维加斯学习》的故事中涵盖了很多这些内容。我的意思是，他们成为了拉斯维加斯建筑的倡导者，大多数人，甚至像我这样的人，我在拉斯维加斯的AA会议上演讲时，有人写信给我说，我不敢相信我们在拉斯维加斯做这件事。
There's nothing of value there and I was like there's like a whole book about it. And it's like a long time we've turned around this thinking and you know in general we should think about what people go to, you know, because, you know, that's worth evaluating why they want to be in places like Las Vegas. I mean, it really does teach us something. Yes, exactly. Like, that demand is there for a reason. And, you know, like a giant fiberglass fesant or a swine ball might, I mean, yes, it's
那里没有什么价值，我说那里有一整本书是关于它的。很长一段时间以来，我们已经扭转了这种想法，你知道，总的来说，我们应该思考人们去哪里，你知道，因为，你知道，评估他们为什么想去拉斯维加斯这样的地方是值得的。我的意思是，它确实教会了我们一些东西。是的，完全正确。这种需求是有原因的。而且，你知道，像一只巨大的玻璃纤维野鸡或一个猪球，我的意思是，是的，它
silly and it comes off as silly, but people are drawn to these stories and stories behind them and the people who've made these objects because it tells you a lot about, you know, the region and the people who live there. Right. I mean, since they were a reaction to the way that we travel and as we were beginning to bypass a lot of these towns and they became attractions for those reasons, our roadside attractions continuing to evolve as travel evolves right now. Yeah, and I asked Nelson this question because we're not in the rapid expansion phase of road travel anymore. For the past few decades we've been doing air travel and with climate change we're kind of more aware of our carbon footprints
很傻，看起来很傻，但人们被这些故事、背后的故事以及制造这些物体的人所吸引，因为它告诉了你很多关于，你知道，这个地区和住在这里的人的信息。没错。我的意思是，既然它们是对我们旅行方式的一种反应，而当我们开始绕过许多这些城镇时，它们就成了这些原因的景点，我们的路边景点是否随着旅行的发展而继续演变？是的，我问了尼尔森这个问题，因为我们不再处于公路旅行的快速扩张阶段了。过去几十年来，我们一直在进行航空旅行，随着气候变化，我们对碳足迹有了更多的了解，
and also the little bit of more, a little more aware of our carbon footprints. We're trying. But like, yeah. The world's largest ball of carbon. Okay. We've got that. We definitely have that. But yeah, I asked her about this because I was kind of curious.
而且也有一点点，对我们的碳足迹有了更多的了解。我们在努力。但是，是的。世界上最大的碳球。好吧。我们有那个。我们绝对有那个。但是，是的，我问她这个问题是因为我很好奇。
And it's still a little bit of a question mark. I'm not sure yet. I mean, will there be a whole new set that's around mass rail or artwork in airports has really exploded too? Artwork has happened in that controlled environment, roadside attractions that really haven't inlet area because they're so controlled. I don't know. Would there be a slow version in cities that's just alleyway embellishments at the new roadside just the sidewalk? A little tiny thing on your path to the next Starbucks? I think that that's right on the money. Yeah. I mean, just because like there's all these types of little artistic interventions and urban landscapes and maybe they've always been there. I don't know if they
这仍然是一个问号。我还不确定。我的意思是，是否会有一套全新的围绕大众铁路的东西，或者机场的艺术品也确实爆炸式增长了？艺术品发生在那种受控的环境中，路边景点在受控区域内确实没有入口。我不知道。城市里是否会有慢速版本，只是小巷装饰，新的路边只是人行道？在你去下一家星巴克的路上的一点点小东西？我认为这正中要害。是的。我的意思是，仅仅因为城市景观中有所有这些类型的艺术干预，也许它们一直都在那里。我不知道它们是否
they function as attractions exactly but they are about embedding art in the built world and that seems like that impulse is there but she's definitely right about airport art. Yeah. Like I travel a lot these days and Airport Art is really good. The exhibits at SFO and in the mural at the Oakland Airport are just stunning. I love them and I look forward to seeing them for a while that was like old board games and it was just like a exhibit of old board games in SFO And I would totally stop at that museum. Yeah. I would. If it was, you know, like on the side of the road in Kansas,
它们是否完全作为景点发挥作用，但它们确实是关于将艺术嵌入建筑世界，这种冲动似乎确实存在，但她在机场艺术方面绝对是对的。是的。就像我最近经常旅行，机场艺术真的很棒。旧金山机场的展览和奥克兰机场的壁画简直令人惊叹。我喜欢它们，我很期待看到它们，有一段时间那是旧棋盘游戏，它只是旧金山机场的一个旧棋盘游戏展览，我绝对会停在那家博物馆。是的。我会的。如果它，你知道，在堪萨斯州的路边，
I totally would go to the old board game museum in Kansas. Well, that's great. I'm glad you didn't die. I'm really glad I didn't die too. Thank you for saying that. But one last thing about the world's largest version, wait, the world's, I don't think I could do this, the world's largest collection of the world's smallest
我绝对会去堪萨斯州的旧棋盘游戏博物馆。好吧，那太好了。我很高兴你没死。我也很高兴我没死。谢谢你这么说。但关于“世界之最”的最后一个问题，等等，世界的，我不认为我能做到这一点，“世界上最大的最小版本事物收藏”，
versions of the world's largest things, is that they have a theme song. And I would love to play that over with this. Oh, let's do it. Let's do this. We'll go out on this. So thank you so much for that. Thank you.
它们有一首主题曲。我很乐意播放它。哦，让我们做吧。让我们做这个。我们以此结束。所以非常感谢你。谢谢。
Thank you. And... Zee-oh! 99% invisible was produced this week by Vivian Lee, edited by Emmett Fitzgerald, mixed in tech production by Sriviusif, music by Sean Riyal. Katie Mingle is our senior producer, Kurt Colestay, the digital director. The rest of the team is Avery Truffle, Joe Rosenberg, Delaney Hall, Sophia Klatsker, and me Roman Lars.
谢谢。还有……Zee-oh！本周的《99% Invisible》由Vivian Lee制作，Emmett Fitzgerald编辑，Sriviusif进行混音和技术制作，音乐由Sean Riyal创作。Katie Mingle是我们的高级制作人，Kurt Colestay是数字总监。团队的其他成员是Avery Truffle、Joe Rosenberg、Delaney Hall、Sophia Klatsker，以及我Roman Mars。
A very special thanks to Josh Johnson, John Dixon from Ripley's Believe It or Not in Branson, Missouri. Special thanks to Grace Lee, that's her sister. Yes, my sister. And to Andrew Zilt for tipping us off to that story of large Twine Bands. You can find out more about the world's largest collection of the world's smallest versions
特别感谢Josh Johnson，密苏里州布兰森市“信不信由你”博物馆的John Dixon。特别感谢Grace Lee，那是她姐姐。是的，我姐姐。还要感谢Andrew Zilt向我们透露了大型线团的故事。你可以在Facebook上或访问worldslarchestings.com了解更多关于“世界上最大的最小版本事物收藏”的信息。
of the world's largest things on Facebook or by going to worldslarchestings.com. The world's largest things theme song is by B-O-M-B, big one man band, which is a project of artist Bruce Humphries. We are a project of 91.7 KALW in San Francisco and produced on Radio Row. You wanna do this with me? In... In beautiful, downtown Oakland, California. Nice. 99% of visible is a member of Radio Topia from PRXF, fiercely independent collective of
“世界之最”主题曲由B-O-M-B（大单人乐队）创作，这是艺术家Bruce Humphries的一个项目。我们是旧金山91.7 KALW的一个项目，在Radio Row制作。你想和我一起做这个吗？在……美丽的加利福尼亚州奥克兰市中心。不错。《99% Invisible》是PRX旗下Radio Topia的成员，这是一个由
the most innovative shows in all of podcasting. Find them all at radiotopia.fm. You can find the show and join discussions about the show on Facebook. You can tweet me at Roman Mars in the show at 99PI org. We're on Instagram and Reddit too. But we got big pictures of giant balls at 999PI.org. Can I do a giant balls joke? I think it's required, right?
播客界最具创新性的节目组成的激烈独立的集体。在radiotopia.fm上找到它们。你可以在Facebook上找到该节目并参与讨论。你可以在Twitter上关注我@RomanMars，关注节目@99PIorg。我们在Instagram和Reddit上也有账号。但在99PI.org上有巨型球的大照片。我可以讲一个巨型球的笑话吗？我想这是必须的，对吧？
Yeah, I think so. We made it most of the piece without making a giant balls joke, so I think we deserve it. That's why we've earned it. People, we've earned it. We're good. our day. Radio Tapio. From PRX. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
是的，我想是这样。我们在没有讲巨型球笑话的情况下完成了大部分内容，所以我认为我们应得的。这就是为什么我们赢得了它。伙计们，我们赢得了它。我们很好。我们的一天。Radio Tapio。来自PRX。本集还没有评论。点击转录中的任何句子来发表评论。